what is up guys today we are talking
effed up movies and some of the most
screwed up scenes that we've ever seen
in a movie and we have an awesome panel
to talk about it with we have the cast
and director of the movie cheap thrills
which is super delightfully effed up in
the best way possible let me introduce
our panel first he plays Craig in the
movie oh he's a friend of the show Pat
Healy next the director of the film al
Katz and he plays Vince in the film
ethan embry so let's talk cheap thrills
it's a pretty effed up movie some crazy
stuff like human beings are pushed to
their moral and emotional limits in this
movie oh we're doing that stuff cut your
pinky off $25,000 it should thank you
you use it for like nothing good I'll do
it let me know if this is accurate it's
like the worst game of like truth or
dare ever yes I was watching this movie
I was trying to put myself in the
situation like would I do that and then
at a certain point I'm like young I
haven't a pan out there's no way I think
if we were all actually in that
situation one of us wouldn't tap out you
can't know
so let's transition and start talking
about some of the most effed up movies
Pat is there a movie scene that stands
out as super stuff I keep thinking about
this these two scenes and I think it's
because it was such a small child when I
saw them from the 1978 version of Asian
of Body Snatchers with Donald Sutherland
there's a homeless man who plays a banjo
and has a dog and when the pods come are
sat next to him him and the dog get
merged together and we later see the dog
with the banjo man's face oh that's
right and then the very end of the film
when Veronica Cartwright walks up the
Donald Sutherland thinking that he's
cool and he turns around and he does
that crazy screech always gets under my
skin
I remember the first time when I was
really young I saw the Hellraiser
boobies being really young and watching
these Santa bytes walk around it was
like right out of my [ __ ] nightmares
like it's me you solved the box we came
now you must come with us honestly like
the scariest thing you know it's like
little children like the guy going on a
date and like jerking off in the car
television that to me is what my modern
sort of like being creeped out by I
remember when I first saw Midnight
Express when I was a teenager we were
talking about this earlier out of the
blue there's this one scene where he
starts having yoga with his cellmate and
it's all like misty and sky lit from the
heavens they touch each other on the
face and they almost kiss and then it
cuts to understand where he bites the
tongue out of a cat like it's like what
is this you always seen doing there's a
guy who sort of has cornered the market
on despairing movies from Japan yeah
Takashi Miike
who made audition and he made a film
called Ichi the Killer which the entire
movie is disturbing but the opening
scene is a man watching a man rape a
woman from a window and he's
masturbating watching and then when he
ejaculates the title of the movie raises
out of his steaming pile of ejaculate
and that's just the because the opening
and you mention audition
the final torture scene in that movie is
it's not only just grueling to watch but
so surprised well that whole movie is
another movie and you don't if you don't
know anything about it you're we're just
watching a movie about a nice old man
trying to find a date or whatever
somebody to take care of them and then
again it comes as just the sound of the
yeah don't worse sound effect I've ever
heard
I saw the yellow his Achilles heel cut
these dicks an exacto knife into his
Achilles and you're sitting there trying
to reach and grab the tendon back out
and pull it backwards they do that in a
hostile - yeah just another like if you
want to get it like the the hostel and
the Saw movies human centipede
I watched human centipede with my mom on
this what one of the things our human
centipede yeah it's super effed up when
the actual creature the Senate human
centipede is introduced who are you hey
yeah but aside from that it's like to
buy its anticipation porn it's a good
afternoon popcorn movie right you also
know where you're in forwards like if
you watch something like seven has some
of the most disturbing yeah great film
right oh yeah the guy that's being kept
alive in the bed without the tongue and
all the air fresh yes you mentioned the
Hellraiser movie as a kid a movie that's
a little more innocuous you would think
but has a frightening sequence in it
Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory
when they go down that river and that's
out of nowhere and you're the kid not
expecting that nightmare yeah it's like
a drug freak out but the yeah gene
Wilder was so brilliant and they're
certainly not shy
[Music]
so we've hit a lot of like the obscure
movies and horror films I think one of
the movies that could open the door for
more mainstream movies to have super
effed up stuff and it is Pulp Fiction I
always think about the adrenaline it's
also really drawn out like De Palma
you're talking about it's like very like
you know you make you really wait for it
[Music]
[Applause]
you'd mentioned David Lynch earlier
Eraserhead when that baby is revealed
not before after I've been so happy that
it was still light outside when I left
the movie theater yeah that is a living
nightmare another movie that has
multiple effed up scenes in it requiem
for a dream there's ask to ask Jared
Leto's arm even Ellen Burstyn 'he's
performance of this drug-addled older
woman taking styles
we're given the prices away really
that's like the kind of movie that's
really good but I never ever want to
watch it again
alright let's boil it down done to your
head if you had to pick the most effed
up movie scene can it be something that
I already said sure it's definitely that
opening scene from each of the killer
even though technically the movie gets
more crazy I mean I just can't believe
that so audacious to open a movie that
way yeah I you know I'm gonna bring up a
Henry again Henry portrait of Sir
Michael Rooker who you know from the
walk time days and yeah after they kill
those people and then they're watching
the tape together
it's just real Ethan there's a handful
of scenes and I saw the devil they cause
me to curl into a ball like the taxi
scene when he's in the taxi and that 360
shot that goes around the taxi as he's
stabbing the driver and the passenger
it's just
I'm gonna have nightmares how about you
so what's the most screwed up scene that
you can think of from a movie what did
we forget about leave us an answer in
the comment section below
coolest answer you're gonna get a screen
junkies t-shirt I want to thank my panel
Pat Healy Gail Katz Ethan Embry from
cheap thrills it is in select theaters
and available on-demand starting on
March 21st see it with a crowd in the
theater and you can all recoil in horror
together thank you gentlemen
I want to thank you guys for watching
screen junkies I'm Hal redneck hit me up
on Twitter bye-bye
Prince of Persia well it's not the best
action film of all time it's
aesthetically pleasing remove the
casting solid I thought oh yeah all
right you know could be a little more
Persian